okay we're back with our main story
today the German parliament in the next
few hours set to vote on what many
consider an historical wrong what
happened to Armenians in Turkey during
the days of the Ottoman Empire in World
War one let's go now to Christopher a
spring gate he's standing by with the
head of the Green Party Jim Ulster mayor
the man who initiated the bill that's
being voted on today Christopher that's
right Brian Jim is Damir with me one of
the driving forces behind this
resolution mr. ohmae what kind of signal
are you hoping to send to the outside
world assuming this resolution does get
passed today 101 year officer did
genocide I think it's time for a
recognition it's time that we as the
country that unfortunately was at the
side of the Ottoman Empire knew exactly
what was happening takes responsibility
we acknowledge yes it was a genocide we
take our part of the responsibility and
obviously that's also sends a signal to
Turkey that we encourage our friends
there to take a second look into what
happened there what sort of reaction are
you expecting from Ankara well it
depends on which Ankara the official
Ankara obviously not a very nice
reaction as always when the Armenian
Genocide is mentioned independent from
what kind of government you have in
Turkey but there is another turkey when
you talk without media directly people a
lot of people tell you stories that you
would never hear officially and you
would never find in history book and
that is the other Turkish history which
is the unofficial story that is not
never told anywhere which includes
stories you know that people tell that
their grand grandmother was armenian
which includes stories that people tell
that the people who used to live in this
house used to be Armenians so there is
an unwritten story that waits to be one
day told now Germany's Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier was initially
against this resolution he called it
clumsy in the against the backdrop of
the beginnings of reconciliation between
Armenians and Turks is this resolution
coming at the wrong time
well it's always
the wrong time you know since 101 year
it's wrong time to talk about our
responsibility and our guilt and you
know if there would be a process of
reconciliation I would be the first
person and I was for a long time I mean
there are articles of mind telling
exactly the same story that frankly the
right Steinmeier is telling us today but
unfortunately let's face it it was mr.
Aird one who stopped that process there
was such a process and it's not the only
process several attempts have been there
including one of the most outspoken
leader of Turkish nationalism mr.
Turkish who was talking to the Armenian
president of that day and the last one
was the Syria protocol which included by
the way a commission of experts that
Turkey claims that Turkey once instead
of the recognition by by German
Parliament and other Parliament's so
Turkey had that opportunity one part of
the deal was the opening of the board to
Armenia and it was Turkey that stopped
that deal so I don't see unfortunately I
wish to say something else that there is
any outlook that under erred one
anything will happen into that direction
so I think it's time as friends of
Turkey to tell Turkey this is the wrong
path one last question mr. Estonia we
hear that
several lawmakers in the German
parliament have been receiving hate
mails negative comments on social media
are you one of those lawmakers well
obviously just look in my Facebook
account or Twitter account and you will
read those kinds of reactions some of
the reactions are really let me say
interesting they say there was no our
main in genocide unfortunately we have
over seen you so what does that say you
know we've over seen you so there was no
genocide but unfortunately we didn't
kill everybody so but let's forget about
that we shouldn't talk about that I
think there are two messages one a lot
of people have questions they don't know
where to ask them because they don't
find appropriate answers in Turkish
history books and they don't find a
place where they can disgust and ask
those questions so I think this should
be the starting point of the discussion
and second I hear a lot of things like
threats let's face it you know if I vote
in favor of that resolution nothing will
happen to me you know I will not go into
prison
I will not lose my job the ones who
really have to show courage are the
people in Turkey so you know let's be a
bit relaxed when we're living in a
democracy nothing will happen to us
okay mr. mayor thank you very much for
though for that the views thereof Jim is
demure the co-leader of Germany's
opposition greens back to you in the
studio Brian